hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion sechs hört zu und
spricht nach was machst du gern was
machst du gern ich spiele gerne fußball
ich spiele gerne fußball ich schwimme
gerne ich schwimme gern
ich spiele gern basketball
ich trinke gern kaffee ich trinke gern
kaffee
ich tanze gern ich tanze gern
[Musik]
ich kaufe gerne schuhe ich kaufe gerne
schuhe
ich reise gern ich reise gern
ich hätte gern ich hätte gern spielst du
gern fußball spielst du gern fußball
ja ich spiele gerne fußball ich spiele
gern fußball
nein ich spiele nicht gern fußball
was machst du nicht gern
was mag
du nicht gern ich putze nicht gern
ich putze nicht gern
ich habe
nicht gern ich arbeite nicht gern
ich bezahle nicht gern die rechnung
ich koche nicht gern
ich lerne nicht gern
ich gieße nicht gern die blumen
ich fliege nicht gern
ich fliege nicht gern ich telefoniere
nicht gern
ich telefoniere nicht gern
was machst du am montag
ich gehe ins kino
was machst du am dienstag
was man
hast du am dienstag ich putze die
wohnung
ich putze die wohnung montag
montag dienstag dienstag/mittwoch
mittwoch donnerstag donnerstag/freitag
freitag/samstag samstag/sonntag sonntag
januar januar/februar februar/märz märz
april april mai juni juli juli/august
august/september september/oktober
oktober/november november/dezember
dezember ich lerne ich lerne
du lernst du lernst wir sie es lernt ihr
sie es lernt wir lernen wir lernen
ihr lernt lernt
sie lernen sie lernen
ich spiele ich spiele
du spielst du spielst
[Musik]
es spielt er sie es spielt wir spielen
wir spielen
ihr spielt ihr
spielt sie spielen
sie spielen
ich arbeite ich arbeite
du arbeitest du arbeitest er sie ist
arbeitet er
sie es arbeitet wir arbeiten
wir arbeiten hier arbeitet arbeitet sie
arbeiten
sie arbeiten
ich öffne ich öffne du öffnest du
öffnest er sie es öffnet er sie es
öffnet wir öffnen
wir öffnen
er öffnet ihr öffnet sie öffnen
sie öffnen
ich putze ich
kunze du guckst du kunst ihr sie es
putzt ihr sie es putzt
wir putzen wir putzen ihr putzt ihr
putzt sie putzen sie putzen ich
reise ich reise du weißt du reist er
es reißt sie es reißt
wir reisen
hier reißt reist sie reisen
sie reisen
[Musik]